Lillian Bonsignore:
This is the cool part.
This is the cool
part of the job.
Lots of lives are
gonna be saved
by these people,
lots of lives.
Narrator: This is Lillian
Bonsignore,
The Fire Department
of New York's
very first female and
openly gay EMS chief
in the organization's
154-year history.
Bonsignore: I talk about
my wife openly.
So it's OK that we
have this conversation.
I'm comfortable with it.
I think there are lots of folks
that need examples and
role models,
that need to know that,
whatever box somebody is
willing to put you in,
doesn't mean you
have to live there.
Narrator: Lillian started out
as an emergency
medical technician
on an ambulance in
the Bronx 28 years ago,
and, since, she's worked
her way up
to the highest-ranking
position.
She now runs the largest
emergency-medical-system
force
in the entire United States.
Her team's a part of
the fire department,
but these folks are
paramedics and EMTs.
They work on ambulances,
respond to 911 calls,
and provide on-the-scene
medical care.
Bonsignore: That means
there are 4,000-plus
EMTs and paramedics that
staff our ambulances,
that service
our five boroughs,
and my job is to
oversee that
and make sure that
we are providing
the highest level
of medical care
to those people who
need us the most.
Man: Everybody clear?
Clear, Joey?
Everybody clear?
Continue CPR.
Narrator: Born and
raised in the Bronx,
Lillian says she had
a tough childhood
and credits her success to
a few key women in her life.
Bonsignore: Along my
way, very strong women
just magically found
themselves in my path,
and they decided
to take an interest
in a kid that needed
help and, you know,
maybe was a little
broken growing up
in a tough neighborhood
with difficult circumstances.
Narrator: It was actually
Lillian's pediatrician
who suggested she
become an EMT.
Bonsignore: I didn't know
what an EMT was,
but I trusted her with
everything that I had,
and I took this job
for the summer,
and it's been 28 years,
and it's the longest
summer job I've ever had.
Narrator: She moved up the
ranks
in the Bronx and Brooklyn
to lieutenant, captain,
and station commander.
Along the way,
she became an instructor
at the EMS Academy
and endured the grueling
paramedic's training.
She was also among
the first responders
during the terrorist
attacks on 9/11.
When Lillian was 30 and
serving on the force,
she came out as gay.
She's now married and
has two daughters.
Bonsignore: There have
been a couple of men who
maybe believed that
a woman's place
is not in the
fire department,
and, you know, they
don't really appreciate
maybe an alternative
home situation,
but that is their
issue to come around to,
that's not really
my concern,
but I will save their
lives as quickly
as I would save the life
of the woman
that I've loved
for 18 years.
Narrator: After 28 years
of service,
in May 2019,
Lillian was promoted
to the fire department's
chief of EMS,
serving the entirety
of New York City.
Bonsignore: Today, I can
stand here
and accept a promotion
to the highest position
in FDNY EMS,
even though I'm a woman.
Today, I can stand here next
to the woman that I love,
and enjoy the spirit
of this special day,
when there are more
places in this country
that you could be fired
for being a member
of the LGBTQ community.
Those females that
are out there and
didn't have a role model,
and didn't have
somebody to say that,
yes, this is a possibility
for you,
now they do,
and I take that
responsibility
on wholeheartedly.
Narrator: But Lillian isn't
entering the role at
the easiest of times.
Call volume is up,
having risen 4.6%
from 2017 to 2018.
EMS responded to
a record-breaking
1.5 million
911 calls last year.
EMTs are making the move
to higher-paid positions,
like firefighting,
at a staggering rate,
and response times across
EMS in New York City
have risen to
life-threatening heights.
Bonsignore: This is a
very tough job.
That is something that
people don't
really recognize.
Sometimes they
think of EMS
as being
ambulance drivers,
but the reality is,
the things that EMS
people see in their jobs,
let's say over the
course of a month,
may be things that
people will never see
in the course of
their lifetime.
Narrator: Lillian says
her EMTs and paramedics
are also facing a growing
array of daily issues:
long hours,
assault from patients,
patients with
infectious diseases,
and, sometimes, dangerous
service locations.
She's on a mission
to make the public
aware of these realities
and honor those
who take on the sacrifice.
Bonsignore: These people
come every single day
with a smile on their face,
knowing that
these challenges exist,
and they work to
push past these things
just because they
know it's right.
Narrator: As for Lillian,
she loves the job,
and plans to use
her new position
to lift up young
folks in her community
struggling like
she once was.
Bonsignore: We have a
very high suicide rate
in the young LGBTQ
community,
and they need us.
They need somebody
to invest in them
like these women
invested in me.
It was truly life-changing,
and if you think a few
minutes doesn't matter
in somebody else's life,
I can tell you
that you're wrong.
If you think that,
if you invest heavily
in somebody
who's struggling,
that they won't
appreciate it
or it won't guide
them to success,
I can tell you that
you're wrong
because the only reason
that I'm here today
is because that happened.